[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
So nice to see you all.
Hope everybody is
having a great week.
Beautiful here in Boston today.
I think it's about 70 degrees.
But I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our pro
community at Posit.
And the Data Science
Hangout is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and
getting to hear
what's going on in
the world of data
across different industries.
And so it happens
every Thursday.
Pretty much every
single Thursday
unless it's a holiday at
the same time, same place.
So if you're watching this
recording at some point later--
on YouTube, you can add it to
your calendar details below.
But every week, we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host to help lead
our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
So together, we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everyone.
We love hearing from
everybody no matter your level
of experience or area of work.
So it is totally OK to
just listen in if you want,
but there's also
three ways you can
jump in and ask questions or
provide your own perspective
on certain topics.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat
and just put a little
star next to it
if you want me to
read it out instead.
And then we also
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And I think Curtis, you
can grab that Slido of link
and share it in the chat.
But I'm so excited to have
Natalie joining us here today.
Natalie O'Shea is the analytics
consultant at BetterUp.
And Natalie, I'd love to start
with having you introducing
yourself, and maybe share a
little bit about your work
and something you like to
do outside of work too.
Sure, yeah.
So as Rachel said, I'm Natalie.
Yeah, I'm an analytics
consultant at BetterUp,
and a lot of the work
that I'm doing right now
is focused actually on building
a flexible, scalable reporting
system in Shiny.
And I'm fresh on that
right now because I just
finished recording my
posit conference talk.
So hopefully, maybe going
to share some of those
learnings there.
Yeah, I could go on and on.
I have a very long and winding
road to where I ended up,
so lots of diversions and
different experiences.
But yeah, outside of work--
I've got my drum kit here.
I have not been practicing
as much as I should,
but that's a hobby
of mine, trying
to learn how to
drum as an adult.
I never learned a
musical instrument when
I was growing up and then I
saw one of my favorite bands
at a jazz club and I
was like, all right,
I need to learn to drum.
So I'm a very bad drummer.
I will also say my birthday was
yesterday or the day before.
Now I'm forgetting but--
Happy birthday.
Oh, thank you.
I'm bringing it up
because a new hobby--
no not quite a hobby, but
I got to meet beluga whales
at the Shedd Aquarium and
that was pretty awesome.
So now I'm wanting to become
a whale trainer as well
on the side.
We'll see about that.
I love it.
That's awesome.
Well, said your favorite band.
Who's your favorite band?
It's a band called lettuce.
Yeah, they're like a
jazz funk hip hop band.
They're very fun.
Yeah.
Cool.
So while we wait for questions
to come in from everyone,
I thought it would be
helpful to put ourselves
in the mindset of some of the
work that you do at BetterUp.
Would you be able to share maybe
a few use or a use case that
comes to mind for
your data team?
Yeah.
So the whole approach
I'm building right now,
it's a big--
I'm a consultant though.
I'm not really directly
consulting as much right now,
I'm supporting a lot
of our consultants.
But as consultants,
they need to be
able to customize reports and
presentations for partners.
So I built out a
system within Shiny
to actually populate
slide decks with metrics
and visualizations.
And I can go on and
on about the reasons
why I took that approach,
but a big reason why
I wanted to have all of that
populate in Google Slide
decks was so that we can
customize the look and feel
and the story of any given
company's data specifically
tailored to them.
And so yeah, I can go on and on
about why I chose that approach
over something like
parameterized reporting, which
I'm also a big fan of, but yeah,
that's a big project of mine
right now.
And then in addition to
that, we know each other
because I've been leading
a pretty major procurement
effort, and we're
in the final stages
now of installing
Posit software.
So we're really
excited about that.
But I learned a
lot about what it
takes to build a business
case for data science
tooling at your
organization, and getting buy
and across the org.
And it's a pretty major
lift to get something
like that off the ground.
What was one of
the biggest lessons
learned in building
business case?
I would say--
one of the biggest
lessons learned
in building the
business case was
have a flagship project that
ties to direct business value.
So the project that
I'm doing really
helps automate a
lot of our processes
and makes it a lot faster
and easier and more
streamlined to populate these
decks with different data
insights.
And so that was
enough of a driver
showcasing the
additional flexibility
that open source programming
tools offer us over a more
business intelligence tool.
That was really a
big driver in what
led us to get this software.
So I'd say having a project
that you can directly
tie to business value, that's
a big big learning from it.
And then I'd say another
learning from it--
I would never have been able
to get this push through if I
didn't have a supportive
manager who really walked me
through the whole process
and helped me navigate
a lot of the
organizational hierarchy
to get something like
this off the ground.
So finding and
developing your community
of allies that are also
interested in the same thing
as you.
You're definitely not going
to be able to do this alone.
Well, Thank you
so much for that.
That's really helpful.
And your data team at BetterUp
I think is a mix of R and Python
users, is that right?
Yes, yeah.
And are they going to
use this environment too?
Yes, yeah.
I'm really-- sorry, my dog
is chewing out my plants.
Fudge.
What's your dog's name?
His name is Gino.
OK.
Everyone here is a
Pittsburgh Penguins fan, that's
where the name is coming from.
Yes.
OK, yeah.
So our Python users.
So I've been really
focused on developing our R
community at BetterUp, and we've
made some big strides in that.
The Python user community
tends to be, I'd say,
more focused on machine
learning use cases.
So I've had some
interactions with them--
and I'm using Python
right now in my project,
but we're definitely--
I'd say the user community
is a little more vibrant.
I'm not here to start our
R versus Python debate,
but I do find that
I think R users just
tend to be more quirky and
really excited about R,
and Python users are
like, this is the tool
to get the job done.
And Python is a great
tool to get the job done,
but I'm just such a
fan of our R community.
But one of the ways in which
I reached out to our Python
community when we were going
through this procurement
process was actually
challenging myself
to learn how to use
vetiver for MLOps
and doing that all
within VS Code and Quarto
so that I can showcase,
hey, this isn't just
a tool for R users.
This really is a tool
for Python users as well.
This is how it
could be implemented
in your own workflow,
obviously with a caveat that I
am by no means a machine
learning expert so.
But taking the time to showcase
the capabilities in their tools
and language of
choice, yeah, I'd
say that was also a big
learning from this effort.
That's really valuable.
Thank you.
I just put the link to the
vitiver package in there
if people hadn't heard
of it before too.
I see Tatsu is calling
me out and saying
it's not that nice in Boston.
I would say like 65
is close enough to 70.
At 3:00 PM, it's
going to be not nice.
Maybe not right this second--
TATSU SHIGETA: It is
cloudy, and it's wet.
Rachael, I wouldn't
call that nice.
I'm thinking of the time where
I to get outside a little bit
later.
It's going to be nicer.
TATSU SHIGETA:
That's fair enough.
There's potential.
So Ishwor, I see you
asked a question in the chat
with a little star.
It's a little long
for me to read.
No problem.
You want to read it?
ISHWOR BHUSAL: Yeah, absolutely.
OK, awesome.
Yeah.
Hey, everyone.
I'm a data scientist working
with Nissan based in Tennessee.
Yeah, it's great to
know about Natalie.
Thank you so much for sharing
your experience and insights
about that.
I have been working on the
same near similar environments.
I have been developing few
R finding applications,
and then I have deployed
into our production
server that is RStudio Connect.
But a lot of times, there
have been circumstances
that, when I have
deployed the application
it perfectly runs fine
in my local environment.
And then when it is published
there in the server,
it gives issues, not so
frequently but kind of once
in a while, maybe once in
a month or two or three,
something like that.
And we had to connect, raise
the ticket or contact the admins
and take their help
to resolve the issue.
And then they take
a couple of days.
And meanwhile, we had to
communicate to the business,
"Hey the app is not running.
Apologize.
So, give us a couple of days."
Those kind of issues.
So, have you worked in
those situations ever?
And then, any efforts you
have taken to make the work
seamless or non-disturbing
from the business standpoint?
Yeah, that is
a great question.
And I wish I had one
of my collaborators
here, Harsh, who is
on our DataOps team.
And so another learning,
again, in the vein
of like building a
community of allies
that support you in this work.
I'm very lucky to
have someone who's
really focused on the
installation and deployment
side of things.
Right now we are
actually working
through that exact issue.
So I'm kind of bouncing around
here, but I'm a huge proponent,
I've really love the
Rhino framework for Shiny.
I don't know if you've even
encountered that at all.
But one of the nice
things about it
is that you use renv
for package management,
and so there's a
lock file, right?
With all of your
package sources.
So, we've been working through
some issues with that right
now, because we did get the full
Posit Team suite of products.
So now we're just
having to make sure
that the lock file is reading
from a package manager
instead of like a binary source.
So, I'm a little out
of my depth in terms
of all the specifics
with deployment,
but we're definitely in
the stages right now.
So we just finished installing
Posit and Workbench,
and we are trying to deploy
the app at the moment.
But we haven't quite
finished it out,
because in addition to our
environment package management
stuff that we're working
with, there's also
the Python aspect of the app.
And so, making
sure that we have,
whether it's a Conda
environment or some sort
of PIP environment, something
for the Python environment.
So yeah, we're just ironing
out some of those deployment
issues.
But definitely a
very common problem.
I would say, I can't
quite speak to all
of the technical aspects
of that deployment,
but on the more
human side of things.
One approach that
we've taken with how
we're deploying this app
out to our organization
is starting with our more
internal team and then kind
of slowly ramping it out
so that we don't just
open the floodgates to everyone
and then are kind of like,
putting out fires.
But taking a more slow approach,
so that people know, "Hey we're
in the early stages
of deploying this,
we're still ironing
out the kinks."
I do know that our
DataOps engineers really
focused on making
sure that we employ
a like, infrastructure-as-code
approach to how
we're deploying things.
So anywhere and everywhere that
we can kind of codify things
in Kubernetes, we are.
So there's just a
lot of moving parts
to deploying an
app to production,
even if it's not partner-facing
production but just
internal use.
And I think one of the
big, most important things
about deploying a
Shiny app like this
is want people to trust it.
So I think taking the time and
really building in some buffer
so that you know
that the app is going
to be load-tested and
reliable all of these things,
before it goes out to
people, is a good practice
so that you don't deteriorate
trust in your data products.
ISHWOR BHUSAL: Yeah, absolutely.
I agree.
And then, quite
frankly our team,
like from the
developer standpoint,
from data scientist and data
analysts standpoint, whenever
there was some issues
in the applications,
we have directly
reached out to admin.
And he handles from the
package manager standpoint
and then from the maintenance
standpoint in the production.
But yeah, I think that's
a good suggestion.
I should probably discuss
with him some time
and then get the proper
package manager, or maybe Rhino
now that you included.
Yeah, OK.
I see Catherine, you had some
thoughts on this topic too,
in the chat.
And sorry if I'm putting
you on the spot here.
KATHERINE GERTON: No, that's OK.
Just mentioning, we
use the Posit products
and get back deployment from
our version control repository.
My team kind of has
a workflow where
we do like a dev deployment.
So we have our master deployment
and that kind of sits there.
And we also have a
get-back deployment
from our develop branch.
So any changes that we make can
be tested there, vetted out,
before it goes to the
version of the app
that our customers are using.
And so, that can
kind of troubleshoot
some of those issues
where it's like, "Oh I
forgot I installed the
dev version of a package
on my local thing trying
to get this new feature,"
but you didn't fix your
manifest before it goes
to the deployment, and
so that would break,
and you can find that out
from your dev deployments
before it ever gets to
that customer interaction
interruption.
Yeah.
And a lot of time
funny-but-not-funny thing is
that we perfectly
test in the dev,
and then app application is
running for about two weeks,
a month or so, and then, like
all of a sudden it crashes
in production.
Like, it's frustrating.
And then business
like literally we
make habit to the end
consumers that they can wake up
in the morning and first thing
they open up they open up
the application
report and then all
of a sudden like 10
emails and 10 emails
coming in into the inbox, "Hey
Ishwor, it's not working."
So, those kind of things.
So, yeah, good inputs.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'll just plus
what Katherine said, having
that deployment environment.
And then again, I'm
just going to keep
pushing the Rhino framework.
I think it's fantastic.
There's also some really good
continuous integration features
with that, so that when you
do merge your development
branch into main, you're having
some really good tests being
done to make sure that it can
run in various environments.
So that's part of the
continuous integration,
is a test that like,
"Does this run on Mac?
Does this run on Linux?
Does it work on Windows?"
And as long as all those
tests are passing--
It's not a guarantee
that there won't ever
be something that comes in and
kind of brings it all down,
but building in as many
fail-safes as possible
is always a good practice.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Definitely.
I see-- Oh, sorry.
Oh no I was just thinking
US integration is definitely
a new territory, I think for
many, many data scientists.
I wanted to make
sure to get over
some of the anonymous
questions too, and just
remind people you can ask
questions over there on Slido
as well, if we want to
reshare in the chat here.
But one question was,
"What advice do you
have for consulting work?"
And they said, "I had a
brief experience last year
and it was tough because of
their data-quality issues."
Data quality, that
is like the hill
that I will die on constantly!
Like, I find myself
always making
the case that like,
I know we want
to build these complex machine
learning models or this
or that, but like first
and foremost, data quality.
And I'm excited for
your talk next week,
because I know, one of our
heroes is Emily Ryder--
Reader?
I'm not sure how to
pronounce her last name,
but she's such an
inspiration for like things
like grouped data checks.
So I think, I like living at
that intersection between data
engineering and data
science, and trying
to kind of make sure we have
reliable data pipelines.
Haven't yet gone into
dbt, but that's definitely
something on the agenda.
With consulting.
So, data quality and consulting.
Yeah, that is a
constant struggle.
I think, I really
do take my role--
Again, I'm not as much
external consulting,
but I consult internally
with our teams,
so kind of setting expectations
of what is possible
given our current data
architecture and data quality,
and working closely with
like, our analytics engineers,
to get those data quality
tests built in that
match the level of
granularity that you're
trying to work with.
But yeah, that is
that's a constant issue.
I feel like there is something
else I was going to respond to
with that and now I'm
completely blanking on what
it was that I was
going to address
in terms of the consulting.
Maybe I'll remember it.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: You can tell
us when it comes back to you!
NATALIE O'SHEA: Yeah, it'll just
be like one of those light bulb
moments, like "Bing!
Oh that was it."
Travis, I see you had
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Hey.
I'm curious about the
sometimes boring side of cloud
infrastructure, Radmin.
We're kind of struggling with
this a little bit right now,
thinking about, we are going
to be hiring a cloud architect
soon, and we want that
person obviously to land
Posit products wherever we go.
I don't know anything
about Kubernetes.
I'm glad other people do.
What does that look
like for you all?
Do you have a separate team
that kind of runs that show?
How often do you
interact with them?
Like, what's that look like?
Did you work with these
so-called full service
providers to kind of
get this stuff set up?
Any tips there are
welcome, thanks.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, same boat.
And thank god for the
data engineers that
do love the Kubernetes stuff!
I'm like, "That's great,
I'm so glad you like that."
That's not the world
that I want to live in,
but I recognize its importance.
I will plug one of
the things that we
did to make sure that we were
getting off on the right foot
with all of our Posit
products was we got,
I think three months of,
three or six months, I forget,
of technical account
management support.
So we have weekly TAM
meetings, and that's
kind of where we surface
a lot of these issues.
So if we're having trouble
with a particular deployment,
or we're running into
package installation issues
and we're not sure
how to address them,
our TAM support team is
really helpful and making sure
we get that all set up.
Again, I feel super
fortunate, again,
to the point of build your
group of allies and make--
You're going to need a community
around to build this stuff out,
and we were very lucky to get
the support of our DataOps
team.
So always-- We're in
an interesting stage
in our business right now,
because we are a startup
and we've had kind of more
quick startup-y processes,
and we're at that
stage of development
where we're really
trying to again take
an infrastructure-as-code
approach with how we build out
stuff.
So our DataOps
squad is pretty new.
But I'm a I'm an
anthropologist by training,
so I'm all about relationships.
So, build those relationships
with your data engineers
and those kind of
folks that do this.
In our organization, I know not
every organization does this,
but once a quarter our
product team does a makeathon,
and this is just an
opportunity for us
to team up with other people,
put whatever crazy idea
you have out there,
and then start
to build some of those
cross-functional relationships.
So, one of the makeathons that
we did in the past on our team,
I proposed that like, we need to
start to document and build out
some best practices on custom
application development.
And that was how I
actually built the bridge
between our team and our
DataOps team, because I knew,
I've got to reach out
to our DataOps team
like they can help us define
some of these best practices.
And so yeah, look for
like little, informal fun
opportunities to build
those relationships.
Because that makeathon
then was what got us
that support for getting
the support for installation
of the products.
Because I'm not a Linux admin!
I could not, you wouldn't want
me to set up these products.
So having someone who's
enthusiastic about that
makes all the difference.
And it's really
great, because I think
when you develop
that relationship,
you can also really make it
clear what your needs are.
So, one of the big needs
on our team was simply,
we work from a
Snowflake database.
Getting that connection
set up has always
been a pain for
people, and that was
one of the reasons why we
wanted to get Workbench.
And so now, we have
a close relationship
with our DataOps team.
They understand all of
the intricacies of why
it's hard for us to
connect to the database,
or the connection
isn't stable, or like,
it varies a across
different machines.
And so, our engineer
currently is
working on a very
streamlined process,
so that people don't ever
have to think about setting up
their database connection
they can just log in via SSO
and then get into Workbench
and that's all done for them.
So yeah, I'm not
that person, but I
think I do a decent job
of finding those people
and making sure that they know
that we appreciate their work,
and we need it desperately!
That's awesome.
Rachel, will you allow
me a follow up question?
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Of course.
Go ahead.
TRAVIS GERKE: Oh OK.
Actually, first, that's
good info about the TAM,
because we just had a kick
off with Posit's TAM group,
and it seems like it'll
be really helpful, so
glad to hear that it
worked well for you all.
We'll pursue that as well.
But yeah, the Workbench,
I'm intrigued by this.
So I saw Hadley posting
something recently
about VS Code and Workbench.
Like, what's your experience
with Workbench so far?
I didn't know it
did all that stuff.
And in particular, I'm
very curious about Copilot
in VS Code I know that's not
going to be something that's
in the RStudio-like products
natively, for good reasons.
But is that something
you all are doing
Workbench, so far so good?
Well I don't know about
all the Copilot stuff,
so maybe someone from
Posit can talk to that.
But yeah, that was kind of how I
sold Posit products internally,
because I think--
You know, I'm such a fan of
the new brand rename to Posit,
because I think
previously it was really
hard to make a case for an R and
Python approach to data science
with "RStudio," formerly
known as RStudio products,
because everyone assumed that
that was all you could do.
But like I mentioned
earlier, when
I was kind of going around
trying to make the business
case for this tooling,
I was like, OK,
I know that a lot of our Python
users use VS Code and Python,
so I need to show them
what a piece of their work
would look like in Python
and VS Code on this platform
to kind of fully convince
them that it's not
just theoretical, that yes you
can spin up a VS Code instance.
But like, show
them, yeah, here's
me, little old me,
that doesn't ever
work in VS Code or Python--
not ever but rarely--
spinning up a machine
learning ops kind
of system in those products.
So yeah, we're
definitely using that.
We haven't really
deployed Workbench
out to the broader
team yet, because again
taking that approach of
like, iron out the kinks
first before you open it up
to a broader group of people.
So myself and one
of my colleagues
are kind of working
with our DataOps team
to make sure that it's a really
good experience once we do open
the gates for the rest
of our organization,
and making sure that
our Python users are
able to use their
tools of choice
as well is a big part of that.
Awesome.
Thanks.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
So something that I
wanted to ask you about
is, I know leading
up to this, we
were talking a little bit
about developing communities
of belonging.
And one of the communities
you're a part of
is Data Science by Design.
And I just want to make sure we
chatted a little bit about that
too.
Oh my god, yeah.
I could talk forever
about this community.
So I hesitate-- I'm
technically on the leadership
committee for Data
Science by Design,
which was like, such an
honor to be a part of that.
I've been doing that since
their first meeting last,
what was that?
Summer of 2021?
The pandemic years all
blur together for me.
But yeah, like this community
is just like, small but mighty.
We have a lot of--
So I come from kind of
an organizing background
as well, so doing a lot
of community organizing.
And we have a lot of people in
the community organizing world
there.
And a lot of us are big fans
of Adrienne Marie Brown,
and we've kind of talked about--
who wrote a book that for me
was like, life-changing,
called Emergent Strategy--
and we really have taken the
approach with this community
to focus on, she calls
it in Emergent Strategy,
an "inch-wide, mile-deep"
organizing strategy,
something along those lines,
which is essentially just like
prioritizing quality and deep
relationships and a vibrant
community over the breadth and
the largeness of the community.
So, I think that approach
has been amazing.
So yeah, it's such
a great group.
We do a lot of like,
creative coding stuff.
A lot of the people
in our community--
actually Ijamaka
and Charlotte are
going to be doing a
workshop on, at Posit,
like "Bringing Out
Your Inner Artist,"
or something like that.
So, we've got a
lot of people that
are really interested in the
intersections between art,
design, data science,
community organizing.
Like, it's quite an
interesting mix of people,
but it all kind of
ties together somehow.
I could not recommend
that group more.
We actually have an anthology
coming out pretty soon here.
We released an anthology
last year that was,
what was the title of it?
Now I'm forgetting
because I'm so focused
on this new anthology.
But the new anthology
is "Our Environment."
So we're really talking about
environments, broadly defined.
A lot of environmental
data scientists
submitted work
there, but we also
have topics on things
like community-building,
your local environment,
things like that.
So yeah, I don't
even know quite where
to start with that community.
But again where when you
find a group of people
that's just so supportive--
I think entering
the data science
field can be so overwhelming,
because there are so
many facets to it, and
things that you feel like you
need to be an expert in.
And you don't.
Like, everyone has
their own expertise.
Everyone has their
own lived experience
that they bring
to the table that
is really important for
how we build out things.
So I often find that it's
not the most technical person
in the room that
has the best ideas,
it's the person with the
most direct experience
with the problem that
you're trying to solve.
So yeah, that's a
long winded approach
to say that I absolutely
love that community
and very proud to be
kind of part of it.
That's wonderful.
I see a lot of comments here
on community too, in the chat.
And Alan, I think you just
asked a question here.
I can't read it all right now.
But do you want to jump in?
Yeah, maybe I
wrote too much in a--
Well no I just
meant I couldn't like,
see it that quickly, and then
know if there was a question.
But I think it's in there!
Yeah there is a question
there, eventually.
I think this is probably
applicable beyond Workbench,
but my thinking about
it now really started
when you were talking
about the sort
of gradual expansion of that as
a tool to a broader audience.
And what I'm experiencing
a lot right now
is tension between portfolio
simplification of tools
versus autonomy,
and I wonder what
that conversation was like for
you and your team to consider.
Like, what should the scope
of something like this be?
And what are the
various trade offs
of trying to make
it broadly useful,
maybe being better supported but
having a steeper hill to climb,
versus being autonomous but
maybe less well supported?
And what those
conversations were like?
Yeah.
So I think--
We use Looker a lot internally
as our business intelligence
tool, so I feel like
that's kind of where
a lot of our efforts
as an analytics team
have been devoted to that.
But as great as Looker
is in its many ways,
there are always
questions that you're not
going to be able to answer with
a business intelligence tool.
So we've always had people
working in R and Python
and doing their own analyses.
So I think a big
part of how we sold
that in terms of the
autonomous side of things
is, people are
working internally,
or on their local machines
and things like that,
and that's obviously not
analytics best practice, so we
want to move to a more
cloud-computing kind
of approach.
And that also, in terms
of making the business
case for things like
that, that helps shore up
our digital security.
So, making the case that we
can have a one-stop shop that
supports both R and Python
users in a secure cloud
environment where they get to
use the tools that they like.
You're not forcing Python
users to use RStudio.
You're not forcing RStudio
users to use VS Code.
Like, everyone gets their
cake and gets to eat it too.
I'm terrible at these
kind of phrases.
But yeah I think that was
a big, big part of that.
I think it remains
to be seen, right?
We kind of have a small
developer license group
initially, because we need
to prove that value first.
So that's kind of
a big part of that.
So I think once
people start to see
us producing value and
centralizing on this tool, that
will help us make the case
to expand the developer
community on Posit.
I'm also, we're in the early
stages of developing like,
there's the app
that I'm working on,
but a lot of the logic
that exists in that app,
we're trying to move into,
because it's pulling directly
from our database, and doing
some standard analyses,
we're trying to move that
into an internal package.
So I think once--
There's like,
aligning on the tools,
but then there's also aligning
on the code and the workflows.
So I think internal
package development
is a great inroad to not
only proving the tools value
but also aligning people
on how we work with data.
Because, here I am going
to be like fangirling over
Emily Ryder again, but
she just recently put out
a great blog post
that really laid
out the differences
between SQL, R,
and both Pandas and
NumPy in Python,
and how they handle
nulls differently
and how this leads to completely
different results sometimes.
So, I think it's
really important
to align on workflows, in
addition to aligning on tools.
But I think that those
tools enable the workflow
centralization as well,
if that makes sense.
For sure.
Yeah, thanks.
I really like hearing
the sort of stories
in this moment of
adoption and then
figuring out how to go further
and what those cases are like
and what those team
processes are like.
So yeah, happy you had
success and hopefully there's
more in there I can learn from.
Thanks!
Yeah.
Thank you.
So a question, I remember
we used to always ask
this in the beginning,
but what is something
that you're most excited
about in the year
ahead, when you think
about your data team?
Oh!
Well, I wonder if
she's listening on
this call, but we recently--
So, my best work friend,
from a different part
of the organization, recently
transferred onto our team,
so that we could work
more closely together.
And we are building out this
internal data-processing
package and kind of trying
to develop some onboarding
materials for Posit.
So I feel a little
like, imposter syndrome
and being like "We're
successful with Posit already,"
because we're like just
at the beginning stages
and have so much more to learn.
So I'm most excited
about like, really
working with my friend to build
out the onboarding for all
of this, to build
some shared workflows,
and then to kind of
socialize that more broadly
in our organization.
I think that will clearly
demonstrate the value of why
we invested in
these tools, so it
gets me excited to
think about people
actually like using the
apps we're developing,
people being able
to easily access
all of the different reports.
Like, one of the
first projects we're
planning on doing once we
get all of this really up
and running and all
the deployment issues
kind of like, ironed out, is
building a central landing
page, like from the Posit,
like curating your data science
content or content with the--
what's it? --the Connect Widgets
package, which I'm so excited--
I get really excited
about getting people
to be able to share their work
more broadly, more seamlessly.
So there are so many really
interesting reports and things
that people are doing at our
organization that often don't
have the kind of
reach and impact
that they could, if we just
had a tool so that they could
easily like, deploy
it and just say
like "Here's a URL that
shows all of the reports
that our team has done
on this specific topic,"
and can just go through and see
all of these interesting trends
and tools that have
been developed.
So yeah, I'm very, very
excited about everything
that this new tooling
will offer us, and just
like building that
workflow that makes
things really easy for people.
Yeah.
That's great.
I want to make sure I'm not
missing anybody's question,
so feel free to raise
your hand here on Zoom
or copy back over into the chat.
I don't see too
many over on Slido.
Jared, I think you had a
question earlier about GitHub
actions.
You want to jump in?
JARED WOOLFOLK: Yeah.
Can you guys hear me OK?
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Yes.
JARED WOOLFOLK: Yeah.
Natalie, I just had
a quick question
about your internal checks that
you do for your programming
applications, and if you have
them in an automatic fashion?
Or is this something that you
essentially from the ground up,
trying to build in
checks as you go along
to ensure not only
consistency but integrity
of the data, so you're not
trying to put so many fires out
that it becomes insurmountable?
If that makes sense!
Oh yeah, 100%.
And I feel like I'm just like,
beating this drum of the Rhino
framework, but I'm still fairly
new to continuous integration.
I've done a little bit of
CI/CD stuff with Power BI
before this, but this is my
first time deploying a Shiny
app with continuous
integration, and I did not
develop it from the ground up.
I really love the Rhino
package because it forces you
into some best practices,
and that's one of the things
that it forces you into.
Since deploying the app
with that framework,
I have learned a little bit
more about GitHub actions
and have modified that template.
"You must best practice, Tatsu."
Yeah, so like for instance,
the framework, the way
the GitHub action
is set up, it runs
a series of different
tests on every push.
And I've realized oh
my god this is just,
every time I push a
change to the app,
it's running these
continuous integration tests
and it's just like overwhelming.
So I realized "Oh, I just need
to change the YAML header"
and I can make it so that
it's only on pull request
that it runs these checks.
So, things like that.
So, that was kind of
like, a design thing that
was built into the
Rhino package that
forced me to learn
something that I should
have been doing the whole time.
But I'm in a weird
position now, where
I'm like starting to
become more recognized
as like a Shiny developer.
My organization people are
coming to me for advice
and I always tell them, like,
"I'm giving you this advice
because I've made this mistake
10 billion times before
and it's painful."
So when I'm telling
you like it's worth
learning Shiny modules,
it's because I've
built 10 billion Shiny
Frankenstein apps that quickly
grow in complexity and
then are horrible to debug
and all of these things.
So yeah, that's a long
winded explanation,
but again plugging
the Rhino framework
for forcing me to learn
about GitHub actions.
And then, the things that I
didn't like about the default
settings, that helped me
learn about GitHub actions
because then I needed to learn
how to modify those settings.
So, I'm running linters,
you know, again,
like setting up some deployment.
I don't even fully
understand how
it's testing the runs on
Linux and R and everything--
or Linux, and Mac and all
of these different setups.
But to the vein of
building relationships,
the fact that I had
that in my application
made the DataOps team
take me more seriously,
and they were more willing
to support my efforts
to get this tooling and to get
it built out, because they saw
"Oh you're not just like ragtag
Shiny apps that can never
go anywhere, you're like
building a more robust ways,
and therefore I'm willing to
put in the time and effort
to support you."
Because why would you spend all
this time and effort docker--
or not doc- but like, building
an entire infrastructure
in Kubernetes if the person
that you're trying to help
isn't even building something
in a way that can be maintained.
So I'm a big proponent of
meet your engineers halfway
and you'll have a
lot more success.
So where and when
possible, really, really
try and demonstrate some
robust engineering practices.
Awesome.
Honest I see you have
your hand raised.
You want to jump in?
Yes.
Thank you.
Natalie, so our team
has recently expanded.
We're not a big team,
around three or four people
that use R. Obviously
we're not advanced enough
to get into the Shinies.
But just broadly, do you have
any tips on the best ways
to kind of establish
best practices?
Again we're in our infancy.
We're more like.
"Do we store these R
scripts in our network drive
or in a SharePoint?"
Just in general, we're trying
to come up with some procedures
and standards and it feels like
you've done that before, you've
been there.
I've been there.
I am there, yeah!
I would say like, again,
the anthropologist in me
is coming out, but like,
focus on relationships first.
Because inevitably,
like, what you
define as the best
practice on first case,
like, you're not going to be
doing that best practice like,
six months--
Not always right?
Like, there are certain
things that will stay,
and teaching your team
to use Git branches
and merge into main
and those things
are going to be pretty stable.
But like, there's other
more thorny questions
that are really hard to
build best practices around.
So for example, in our
team, we support a lot
we support a lot of
different organizations
with different data
analyses, and how
do we, like what size of repo?
Do we put everything
into one big GitHub repo
or do we make a repo for every
organization for every project?
It's always in development
and it's constantly iterating,
so being comfortable
with that, I
think is a key
part of developing
best practices,
because it's never
going to be just like a set it
and forget it best practice.
It's going to be
constantly in relationship
and building together
those best practices.
We run an R users office
hours every two weeks.
And I often don't have
an agenda or anything,
and it's a great way to just
first and foremost build
community.
But that's also
where people come
to say like, "I'm really
struggling with this; like, how
do you approach this?"
And now we're starting to
build those best practices.
And as we build out
the whole kind of Posit
onboarding
infrastructure, our hope
is that we end like,
internal packages.
I think building
that into vignettes,
like Confluence document--
I haven't tried
this out yet but I
did see that Quarto
is supporting
like, Confluence
documentation, which
is awesome because our
team uses confluence
pretty significantly.
But I hate anything that's
not like, programmatic.
So I want to have it as a
script in R and I can automate,
or like I can get in R
and alter that script,
but then send those updates.
So yeah, maybe not
the best answer,
but just be comfortable
with iterating
and make sure that you're always
communicating with each other
and building strong
relationships.
Yeah.
That was wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you Natalie.
I think that focus
on relationships
first, that might end up
being the title, of this one!
Greg, I see you have your
hand raised; want to jump in?
GREG SHICK: Yeah I
was just wondering,
you mentioned some
of the reporting
that you're doing out of Shiny.
So are you also, in
addition to Workbench,
are you using Connect?
Yes.
Yeah.
So, the app will be
deployed on Connect,
and then we do a ton of
ad hoc reporting, which
again, right now,
is kind of like,
"Here's a Google
spreadsheet with the answers
to your question," or,
here's at most like,
a PDF of an R markdown report.
But hopefully once we have the
whole infrastructure running,
that will all live
in a landing page
that's continuously updated.
Again, my focus on
parameterizing everything.
But, using the pins package
right to add metadata
to whatever you're
deploying, whether it's
a report and app or
anything, and then
having that all land
in a central page.
Yeah, I think that's one of the
big benefits of the whole Posit
infrastructure.
Absolutely.
We talked about pins
last week I think, right?
Good to hear.
Yeah, absolutely.
GREG SHICK: Thanks.
Lots of love for pins.
I see Jared, you
had asked a question
on recommendations; do
you want to jump in?
JARED WOOLFOLK: Sure.
I think I ask this
about every talk.
But any books that you
recommend, Natalie,
that you have read that would be
of use to this group, I guess?
Yeah, I saw Curtis
recommended the Engineering
Production-Grade Shiny Apps, so
that is definitely a great one.
I find I'm-- well I wouldn't
say I'm not a book learner,
like I've gone through like the
R Packages book and took pretty
detailed notes on that.
So, all of the, I
feel like there's
an R canon which is
like, R for Data Science
first and foremost, then you've
got Advanced R and you know,
R Packages and those things.
So those are always
like, great references.
But I'm the kind of
person that tends
to learn a lot from like
tutorials and things.
So again, I'm bringing
up the Rhino framework
just because I love it
so much, and I basically
learned that just by going
through their tutorial.
And then there's obviously
people within the R community,
that I follow their blogs
and learn a lot from them.
So the system I developed
for this reporting system is
heavily, so it's like built
in the Rhino framework,
but it borrows heavily
from Jiwan Heo,
I think is how you
pronounce his last name.
But he put out a blog
post on using R6 classes
and Gargoyle triggers to
kind of manage reactivity
within your app, and
I wanted to make sure
that people weren't like
accidentally running
a ton of database queries.
So I built the system in a way
to when someone kind of selects
their filters, they
select their filters,
they click the action button.
It runs a dbyplyer query.
It saves the results
of that to an R6
object that I then pass
around to different modules
to build visualizations,
run analyzes, whatever,
and then populate slide
decks by transferring it
to the Google API.
So there's a whole slew
of things there, yeah.
Did I answer your question?
I feel like I lost track
of your original question
there, apologies if I--
JARED WOOLFOLK:
No, that's great.
In terms of books--
NATALIE O'SHEA: Oh, books!
JARED WOOLFOLK: --also if
there's anyone that you follow,
like social media
wise, that you feel
like has been a big influence
on how you've done your work?
Yeah.
JARED WOOLFOLK:
Essentially helping,
you know, the muses and mentors
that you feel like you've
gathered or garnered?
Yeah.
So Emily Ryder, big fan.
She'll be on here next week.
Maya Ganz for Shiny
app development.
Huge influence,
awesome person too.
Jiwan Heo, I really
loved his blog post
on R6 classes and
Gargoyle triggers.
I thought it was a
really clever approach
and completely stole
it for my own work.
But that's the benefit, right?
"Steal like an artist."
That's the name of the talk
that Sharla and Ijamaka
are doing at Posit.
I'm trying to think.
I'm sure I'm missing
other people that
are huge influences.
I mean obviously, like,
all the people from Posit.
You know, Hadley.
And then, like
Jenny Bryan, right?
The amount of times that I have
sent around her thing of like,
"If your script starts with 'set
working directory,' I will come
into your office and set
your computer on fire" is,
I use that a lot!
So yeah, so lots of influences.
There's just such an amazing
community of R users,
and that's what made me want to
continue down this whole career
path.
I love it.
I know we talked a bit
about building a business
case in the beginning,
and we were just
talking about this internally.
Like, is there a way that
I could make this tool
or calculator for people?
And I was just wondering,
in building a business case,
did you actually have
to put a monetary value
to what you would provide?
Or like, saving money
for automations?
I don't know.
Just curious.
Yes, for sure.
And I'll answer that.
I just wanted to,
someone mentioned
integrating design
thinking and data science,
and I just, another
like influence of mine
that's like a blog
post, course, whatever
person is Brian O'Neill.
He does a lot of designing
human-centered data products.
So I'll just plug
his work as also
being a really big influence
and someone you should check out
if you want to build tools
that people actually use,
which I hope we all do.
But yeah, as far
as putting a number
on what we would be
offering, again, I
have the world's best manager.
I could not go on
about that any more.
He's wonderful, and much more
business savvy than I am.
So he helped set me
up with the team.
We did kind of like
a whole, or like--
Now I'm forgetting because
I'm not the business person.
But we did kind of
survey people in terms
of like, how much
time are you spending
building a single slide deck?
Like, where are all the
places that you have to go?
Like on average, you spend, say,
10 hours building this slide
deck.
And then hey, if all
of these data points
were populated
automatically for you,
how much would how much
time would be remaining?
So we kind of used that.
And then obviously,
like, factoring
in people's salaries
and all of these things,
and then came up
with a rough estimate
of the time-cost savings
that building out this app
would have.
And building-- oh
and this is kind
of another good
piece of advice, is
like, the app I've built
now, I don't think anyone
would have been able
to see that if I just
like started with that.
Building MVEs or MVP--
like little pieces of the pie.
Like, I started off doing
parameterized reporting
with R Markdown, and people
were like, "That's amazing!"
But the problem with that
is that I can't quite,
people aren't going to have the
kind of flexibility on the end.
So I'm like, this is great.
This is how we actually populate
slide decks with data insights,
but if you want the flexibility
to change the branding,
alter the wording, all
of this stuff like,
this is our next MVP.
And then you just kind of
work your way up to now
I have a production
grade Shiny app
that does all of this for you.
But always kind of like,
building in little chunks that
get you there.
That's incredibly helpful.
Thank you.
I know that people
are doing this,
but I never know like
exactly how you do it.
So that's cool that
you polled everybody
and ask how much time they
were spending doing something.
These are the fastest
hours of the week,
so I know we're coming
to the end here!
But a question I recently
started asking that I really
like is what's the best--
sorry not best.
What's a piece of
advice that comes
to mind to you
that you've either
given to somebody on your
team or that you've received
over the course of your career?
It could be the best piece, or
just whatever comes to mind.
I don't think I follow
this as much as I should,
because I let my enthusiasm
get the best of me.
But my manager is
always giving me
the advice that is
very well given,
which is under-promise,
overdeliver.
Like, it's classic
advice, but that
is what you need to be doing.
I get so excited about building
the community around stuff
that I'm like, "Look guys,
this is what I did today!"
And I want to grab them
and be like, "How can you
use it and do all that?"
But oftentimes it's better to
just put some brakes on and say
like, "I'm going to make sure
I get this really ironed out."
I document how I did it.
Whatever you need so that it's
not just like, "Hey, watch me
program this and build it up."
That's fine.
I do a lot of pair
programming with people.
But if you can kind
of like, get something
like real nice and streamlined
and professional-looking
before showing everybody,
that's kind of the way to go.
So under-promise, overdeliver.
Best advice that I
often don't follow!
RACHEL DEMPSEY: I
feel the exact same.
Our president was just
telling me earlier today
to focus on a few important
things instead of all
of these important things.
Mm-hmm.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Let
me just double check.
I want to check on
some of the questions,
if I missed anything.
So feel free to put
it back into the chat
or raise your hand here.
But I think it's so cool that
your team does the office hours
and you have this
community group too,
and I was just wondering
a little bit more
about what the office hours
look like, so if somebody wanted
to start that at their team.
Like, is it virtual?
Is it an hour?
Yeah.
So we do one hour
every two weeks.
And we, I think it's--
We've kind of ended
up at this, right now,
just doing like
informal gatherings.
So like, I'm there for
the hour, whoever like,
stops in, if you
have any questions.
Again, just trying to make
sure people know that there are
no stupid questions, like
not being judgmental,
like if you're
struggling with something
that I can spot the
issue in two seconds,
not being like "Why don't
you understand this,
you don't know how to use the
command line, blah blah blah."
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
Just like, "Hey, we
solved a problem together.
This is exciting.
This was fun."
And so that gets people to
want to come back and bring
their questions and
all of those things.
Right now we don't
have an agenda.
We are wanting to hopefully
move, especially now that we're
really starting to iron out
all of the installation stuff
with Posit.
We're hoping to use those office
hours as a time for onboarding
people into that system.
So, hoping to do
little workshop series
on using Git and
GitHub within Posit,
and how to deploy
something onto Connect.
And so, I think
that will give us
like a really nice kind of
series of things to go through,
but it can be hard because
people have their jobs
that they need to do.
And so, building
community is just
kind of one of those things.
I talk to my BetterUp
coach all the time
about like, that's just
how I approach my work.
No matter whether
you pay me to or not,
I'm going to try and
build a community.
Like, that's what
I'm going to do.
Yeah.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
KATHERINE GERTON: I'd like
to jump in, because I--
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Yeah!
KATHERINE GERTON: We have an
office hours set up as well.
And we actually ended up kind
of divorcing the office hours
from the how-tos and
the onboarding things,
because we ended up, you
know the interest in those
has kind of a season.
And so, we would
have like OK, here's
what we're going to talk about
in this week's like R user
group, as opposed to
the R office hours
where people are bringing
those more ad hoc questions.
But definitely, as we
were building up to that,
it was just kind of one meeting.
And then we found, OK we do
the office hours once a month
and the user group once a month,
but on opposite every two weeks
kind of thing.
So it's like, still the two-week
timeline but different focus.
Yeah, I think
that I might have
to take that advice to heart.
I like that.
Yeah.
Yeah it's really
nice to have--
Well, I always think about that
because of the Hangouts too,
it is nice having
the informal session
where anything can
come up as well.
Absolutely.
That's great.
Well thank you so much,
Natalie, for joining and sharing
your experience with us.
If people want to get
in touch with you,
is LinkedIn the best way or--
Yeah.
Yeah, so you can get a
hold of me on LinkedIn.
I do still have a Twitter,
but I haven't really
checked it since the
like, forceful takeover
that, you all know
what I'm talking about.
Haven't been as active on
Mastodon but I'm also on there.
So yeah, happy to chat.
Thank you.
Awesome.
And I want to make sure I share
the Data Science by Design too.
I could share these links
with the recording too.
Please.
Yeah, definitely check out
our new anthology series.
It's going to be, it's
going to be great.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.
Nice to see you.